Avengers endgame was the epic
culmination of over 20 movies released
across more than a decade earning well
over two billion dollars at the global
box office so why would disney
re-release the movie less than two
months after its debut here are a few
reasons one big reason why endgame is
getting another push in theaters doesn't
have anything to do with the Avengers at
all it's another blockbuster that still
holds the top spot at the global box
office tell me his name again
in 2009 James Cameron's Avatar brought
in more than two point seven billion
dollars easily claiming the all-time
box-office crown with its 3d sci-fi
spectacle it's held on to the record for
an entire decade but that era may be
about to meet its end the Avengers made
a major splash with a record-setting
opening with endgame becoming the
fastest film to ever surpass 2 billion
dollars it equips the entire box-office
revenue of its predecessor infinity war
in just 11 days but the new movie soon
began getting pushed out of theaters by
an onslaught of summer blockbusters
leaving it around 43 million dollars shy
of the all-time record after two months
in theaters in hyping up a new release
of the movie it's clear that Marvel is
in it to win it and this scheme might be
just the thing to push the MCU over
James Cameron's otherworldly Odyssey the
fourth Avengers movie already tops out
at a stunning three hour run time and
the re-release will apparently be even
more demanding of the audience but don't
go in expecting the full director's cut
treatment according to Marvel Studios
President Kevin Feige the movie's not
going to include new scenes at least not
before the credits speaking to Screen
Rant the super producer explained that
the end game re-release is not an
extended cut if you stay and watch the
movie after the credits there will be a
deleted scene a little tribute and a few
surprises
rather than being a rillette 'it adverse
of the film psyche implied that the
re-release is more of a quote bit of a
marketing push with a few new things at
the end of the movie but what could
those new things be we don't know but
here are some possibilities the
rerelease could include a deleted scene
featuring 13 reasons wise Kathryn
Langford as Tonia's grown-up daughter
encountering him in the orange sole
world after Tony snap
according to directors Joe and Anthony
Russo that scene was deleted for being
too out there of a story turn at a
critical moment as Joe Russo told the
happy sad confused podcast there was an
idea that we had that Tony was going to
go into the metaphysical weigh station
that Thanos goes into when he snapped
his fingers and that there was going to
be a future version of his daughter in
that weigh station we showed it to a
test audience and it was really
confusing for them there's also a
possibility that this package might
include a previously unreleased sequence
of Lewis from the ant-man movies
recapping the entire MCU which Kevin
Feige confirmed the existence of during
a reddit asked me anything thread in May
according to Feige we did a special
shoot of Lewis recapping the entire
10-year history of the MCU for San Diego
comic-con when we announced Michelle
Pfeiffer playing Janet Van Dyne I'm sure
it's around somewhere and those are just
the possibilities we know about the real
answer is nobody knows what Marvel has
planned for the re-release package but
based on phii's description it's
probably best to temper your
expectations the re-release announcement
was even more surprising considering
that endgame will return to theaters
shortly before the July second release
of the next spider-man film far from
home but it could actually turn out to
be a big boost for Tom Hollands next
outing as New York's friendly
neighborhood web slinger this won't be
the first time Marvel has debuted a new
movie against one of its biggest
performers in early 2018 black panther
and infinity war ended up running
concurrently in theaters and both films
performed massively well at the box
office without stepping on each other's
toes and as far as endgame goes this
won't even be the first time it's
running against another one of Marvel's
own Captain Marvel which was released
over a month before endgame saw a small
bump in ticket sales once it was joined
in theaters by the juggernaut sequel
more than any other MCU movie since ever
endgame feels like a real conclusion
wrapping up a story that spans some fans
whole childhoods with both Iron Man and
Captain America apparently out of the
roster it might be tempting for some
viewers to want to jump off the train
but while one chapter of the MCU may be
ending it's clear that Marvel isn't
ready to bow out of the pop-culture
spotlight re-releasing endgame puts the
movie back in the news for the summer
season making headlines all over the
Internet getting audiences ready for the
final phase 3
and beyond it also keeps the brand name
in the news cycle during the run-up to
July San Diego comic-con and Disney's
d23 Expo in August at which the company
is expected to roll out big
announcements for its upcoming films so
if you're still wondering when the
superhero bubble is going to burst you
might want to get used to the
possibility that it never will you see
no one's going anywhere while some fans
were enthused by the news of endgames
theatrical victory lab it's hard not to
have a cynical view of the announcement
especially with Feige himself calling
the re-release more of a marketing thing
than anything else after all just a few
days before the announcement Anthony
Russo told indieWIRE that he wasn't
focusing on the box office battle
between endgame and avatar so it can't
help but feel like less of an artistic
move than it is a money grab but it
might well be an effective one one more
weekend with enthusiastic Marvel fans
could be all it takes to close the gap
between Avengers and avatar but if that
happens who really wins after it's
high-profile merger with Fox Disney now
owns not only Marvel but avatar as well
in other words the company already has
the two highest-grossing movies of all
time they're just pitting them against
each other it's all on the same page
another less obvious winner is actress
Zoe Saldana who has a prominent role in
both franchises she's blue she's green
she's a billion dollar woman and she's
come a long way from crossroads playing
supporting act 2 Britney Spears hugest
Jones check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about the MCU are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]